merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues partout en
France les réseaux transports en commun
se dégradent et c'est la galère
quotidienne pour les usagers dans toutes
les régions les autorités organisatrices
sont confrontées au même difficultés
avec l'ouverture à la concurrence les
recrutements sont de plus en plus
difficiles et les démissions sont
légions le service se dégrade et les TER
sont pleins en Île-de-France les rampes
de métro tram et RER sont bondés le pire
c'est le réseau de bus qui en grande
souffrance avec des bus annulés sans
raison et sans solution de report
quelques exemples franciliens 80 minutes
d'attente pour le bus 545 à Noisy-le-Sec
ou encore 61 minutes pour le bus 322 à
Montreuil se rendre à l'école au travail
à tout type d'obligation est devenu un
parcours du combattant le pire c'est
qu'en plus d'un service dégradé les
régions qui voient leur budget de plus
en plus contraints et qui refuse
d'augmenter le versement de transport
des entreprises envisage d'augmenter le
prix des abonnements pour les usagers en
Île-de-France le Pass Navigo pourrait
passer de 75 à 100 euros par mois c'est
un supportable pour les millions
d'usagers alors Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est simple quels moyens
supplémentaire sont prévus pour établir
des transports en commun fonctionnels
partout dans le pays
[Musique]